Any movie with as troubled a production as
the new Masters of the Universe is bound to
foster a whole mythology of rumors and speculation.
And by the power of Grayskull, here's all
the latest on the future adventures of Eternia's
greatest warrior.
In early 2019, the final slate of production
staff for Masters of the Universe finally
began to gel.
David Goyer, who'd earlier delivered a script
treatment for the new movie and was briefly
in talks to direct, opted to serve as executive
producer on the project instead due to other
directorial commitments.
In his place, the studio hired the directorial
sibling duo Adam and Aaron Nee, best known
for the comedy Band of Robbers, a modernized
pseudo-sequel take on The Adventures of Huckleberry
Finn with its main characters portrayed as
adults.
Finally, screenwriters Art Markum and Matt
Holloway, best known for their credits on
the original Iron Man, have taken a fresh
pass at the script.
With Goyer and at least four other known writers
having made their own attempts at cracking
the story, it's not yet clear how much credit
any of them will receive, or if any of their
previous ideas will make it into the final
product.
Goyer's script in particular appeared to have
been relatively close to completion, but Markum
and Holloway still reportedly started over
from scratch.
"You are all aware of the penalty for failure."
You can't have a Masters of the Universe movie
without a star to play He-Man, and in 2019,
the new version found its lead in Noah Centineo.
Arguably best known for his work in the Netflix
rom-com To All the Boys I've Loved Before,
Centineo's casting marks more than a slight
departure from his predecessor in the role,
Dolph Lundgren.
This appears to be an intentional move, when
asked about his preparation for the project,
Centineo teased:
"It's a new universe…The Nee brothers, Adam
and Aaron Nee, they're directing it, and they're
the filmmakers in charge of the story, and
they are doing one hell of a job developing
the world and all these things."
A new perspective on the characters and their
setting is to be expected from any reboot
of a well-known property, but, as is always
the case, fans were quick to offer their opinions
on Centineo's casting.
Critical Twitter users called the young actor
everything from "a fine actor, but a poor
choice for He-Man" to downright "pathetic."
Of course, Centineo is far from the first
star to suffer the sting of preemptive scorn,
even Heath Ledger's initial casting as the
Joker was met with outright uproar from comic
fans.
"I thought my jokes were bad."
Dolph Lundgren played the original live-action
He-Man in the 1987 Masters of the Universe
film, and in an era of pop culture callbacks
and novelty cameos, there's no doubt that
many longtime fans would appreciate an appearance
in the reboot.
At one point, Lundgren was indeed actively
sought after for the movie, with previous
director Jon Chu having publicly expressed
an interest in including him in some way.
This interest, however, doesn't appear to
have ever brought about any serious negotiation
towards casting Lundgren under Chu's direction,
and Chu departed the project in 2014.
Lundgren himself has in the past expressed
his own interest in being involved.
In 2012, he called the reboot:
"...a good idea…[but] I wouldn't want to
take my shirt off again for three months."
Lundgren then suggested that he could play
He-Man's father, King Randor, instead.
Of course, that was some time ago, but Lundgren
is still very much around and enjoying a healthy
bump in his celebrity status, having recently
appeared in Aquaman and having reprised his
famous role as Ivan Drago in Creed II.
Getting him involved with Masters of the Universe
would be a fun way to hark back to the franchise's
history that older He-Man fans are bound to
love.
"I have the power!"
When a film such as Masters of the Universe
struggles to find its feet, movie studios
tend to keep production updates very low-key
because of the inevitable fragility of the
pre-production process.
As such, not much is known about how this
new film will actually look.
But a few choice teasers have reached fans
nonetheless.
The only tantalizing peeks we've yet seen
of the new movie's visual conceptualization
came from yet another of the movie's former
directors, Jeff Wadlow.
Wadlow, who was on the project from 2014 to
2017, commissioned prosthetics designer and
sculptor Mario Torres to mock up some busts
of two secondary characters from Eternia:
Beast-man and Ram-man.
Torres later shared images of these sculptures
on his Instagram account, revealing designs
that seemed to indicate a more realistic and
gritty film than the 1987 original.
At 2019's annual Masters of the Universe fan
convention, Power-Con, director Kevin Smith
was announced as a last-minute Guest of Honor
just days before the con began.
This appearance ended up being a surprise
reveal for a brand-new animated Masters of
the Universe limited series for Netflix entitled
Masters of the Universe: Revelation, with
Smith on board as executive producer.
Very little has been revealed about the project
so far, but what is known is that the story
is set to resolve unfinished business from
the original animated series' two seasons,
which ran from 1983 to 1985.
Currently, there is no announced release date,
but the series will be produced by the Powerhouse
animation studio, which was also behind Netflix's
Castlevania animated series.
For the moment, there's no official word and
no reason to believe that this modern return
to the animated source material has anything
to do with Sony's live-action feature film.
It is clear, however, that He-Man's future
is finally heating up, after a very long and
very cold break for longtime fans of the franchise.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.